Welcome to unit 4. Unit 4 is all about asymmetric cryptosystems.
We started talking in unit 3 about the paper that Diffie and Hellman wrote in 1976
that introduced the idea of an asymmetric cryptosystem.
They didn't figure out how to build one quite yet.
They did figure out that key exchange protocol that we focused on in unit 3.
What we'll do in unit 4 is talk about the first successful asymmetric cryptosystem,
which is called "RSA," which is named for its inventors--
Ron Rivest, Adi Shamir, and Leonard Adleman.
We'll look at how asymmetric cryptosystems can be used
that we'll see how RSA is constructed, and we'll go in a fair bit of detail
of why RSA works and why people believe it is secure.
Then we'll look at some of the problems that happen when people use RSA in practice.
Finally, we'll start talking about applications of asymmetric cryptosystems.
We won't get too far in applications in this unit,
but that'll be the main focus of unit 5.
All the cryptosystems we've talked about so far have been symmetrical.
What that means is that the key used for encryption,
and the key used for decryption are the same.
This lead to the problem that we talked about in the previous unit
about how do you distribute this key between two parties,
but even if you can solve that problem using the same key for encryption
as you do for decryption limits what you can do with a cryptosystem.
With an asymmetric cryptosystem we have different keys for encrypting and decrypting.
We'll call one of those keys ku--the u stands for public--
and the other key kr--the r stands for private.
Unfortunately, both public and private start with the same letter p.
That's why we use u and r to distinguish the two keys.
Public is a bit of a misnomer here.
What we really mean is this key does not need to be kept secret.
It's still very important that it's generated in a particular way
and it's associated with the right identity.
Before we get into the scheme for actually building a cryptosystem like this,
and until one is actually built, it seems like this should be impossible.
If we reveal the way we do encryption,
that seems like we also reveal the inverse.
The way to do decryption.
For the cipher to be correct, decryption must be the inverse of encryption.
For most functions when you reveal how you compute the function in one direction,
that also reveals how to compute the inverse.